from secret clues to the upside down's
origins to a stack of terrifying horror
movie easter eggs the fourth season of
stranger things is loaded with things
you might have missed yupikai movie
lovers i'm jan and these are the biggest
best and creepiest details hidden in
season four spoilers ahead so take care
although season four so far has revealed
a lot of new details such as one's
identity and how he ended up as a
villain in the upside down we still
don't know where his powers originally
came from but there's a little clue in
the final episode if you turn the
subtitles on because as one is using his
powers against two the captions read
eldritch power thrumming for those who
don't know the word eldritch means
something weird sinister or ghostly and
is often applied to describe
lovecraftian horrors that are ancient
almost unfathomable and from another
dimension so this could well imply that
even before he became wekner one's
powers originated somewhere in the
upside down the upside down has probably
been around for thousands of years
millions i wouldn't be surprised if it
predated a dinosaur the subtitles also
reveal that eldritch music plays when
wekner kills patrick and that there's
eldritch thrumming when steve nancy and
co find the gate in the upside down and
there's also eldritch gurgling when they
pass through the gate all of which
firmly links the concept of this ancient
power or terror together with the
stranger things alternate dimension
jonathan may be far away from hawkins in
california this season but in his room
as a poster for rem's debut album murmur
a clue to the terror vechna is wreaking
back in his hometown as well as being
the band's name those initials also
stand for rapid eye movement a phase of
sleep known for its often vivid dreams
including lucid dreams where the person
having the dream knows their dreaming
and may even be able to influence some
of the characters stories or setting in
their dream that's especially fitting as
several hawkins inhabitants are
terrorized by waking living nightmares
and it also fits 11 story as well as
she's going through her own type of
waking nightmare as she relives events
from her traumatic past in the rainbow
room plus in the final episode when one
reveals his origins in his villain's
monologue we see a young henry creel's
rapid eye movement as he turns back the
hands of the clock using his powers and
when he attacks his mother and there's
even more to that rem poster because it
shows a field of kudzu a fast-growing
plant regarded as invasive in north
america as it kills off surrounding
vegetation obstructing their access to
sunlight this reminds me of another of
the show's horrors the vines of the
upside down that amassed over hopper and
will in previous seasons the poster's
kudzu image then also links thematically
to hopper's season 4 reveal about his
time in vietnam where he was in the
chemical course spraying herbicide the
first episode gives us several early
signs of max's fate this season after
awkward talks with her school counsellor
and lucas she heads to the bathroom
where the image of her staring at
herself in the mirror echoes will in the
season one finale before he ended up
possessed by the mind flayer the
following season
notice also the graffiti on the walls
with the word cu next to a pair of eyes
and further down the words but do you
see me those all seeing eyes looking at
max in the mirror foreshadow her being
cursed by wekner and how he spies on his
victims from afar reaching into their
minds without their knowledge and the
words on the wall are also echoed in
lucas's later apology for not seeing
what his friend had been going through
all along i just didn't look hard enough
but i see you now i see you oh and
there's also a tiger eye poster on the
wall watching during max and lucas's
argument
beckner's already got a hold of
cheerleader chrissy and her wretching in
the bathroom brings to mind will
vomiting up a creature in the buyer's
bathroom in season one and notice again
more graffiti of eyes looking directly
at chrissy in the stall as she's haunted
by the all-seeing monster also chrissy
being tormented with visions of vechna
and sounds of her mother berating and
bullying her is reminiscent of beverly
being trapped with visions by pennywise
and a toilet stall in it chapter 2.
and the song i was a teenage werewolf
that we hear after chrissy opens the
door was inspired by a 50s horror film
of the same name in which an angry
troubled teen turns into a murderous
monster after being experimented on by a
doctor with his own agenda which
certainly has shades of one's experience
with dr brenner and that same teenage
werewolf movie also appears in it
similar to the way penny wise returns to
derry every 27 years for his killing
sprees which often target children
there's also a 27-year gap between henry
creel murdering his family in 1959 and
his return to hawkins as vechna in 1986
when he begins killing teenagers and
when wekner attacks patrick the time is
27 minutes past nine my rocky wasn't the
only thing that got soaked 9 27 wechner
also puts his victims in a psychic trap
tormenting them with horrifying visions
before moving in for the kill akin to
how pennywise one of the duffer brothers
inspirations for wekner employs the
deadlights to hypnotize a target just
before killing them and uses
psychological traps to terrify them to
make them extra tasty both fechner and
the dancing clown also have their
origins in another dimension and henry
creel's love of spiders also reminds me
of pennywise's monstrous spider form and
if you're enjoying these horror
references so far hit that like button i
really appreciate it not only do
murray's russian language talents prove
crucial again this season but he also
makes use of a more physical skill if
things go sideways i should mention i'm
now a black belt in karate and while
it's funny to see him roughly quoting a
famous okinawan karate master in the
middle of fighting smuggler yuri my
fingers are like arrows my arms like
iron my feet like spears it's even
funnier when you realize that murray's
previous experience of karate i've only
sparred with the other students how old
it doesn't go younger than 13. has a lot
in common with dwight k schrute's karate
classes in the office i am a
practitioner of goju karate the way that
max is framed in this shot at the video
store with a standee of freddy krueger
leering over her shoulder anticipates
her possession by this season's
nightmare on elm street inspired big bad
wekner who terrorizes teens in living
nightmares similar to kruger
and at the psychiatric hospital there's
an extra sneaky nightmare on elm street
easter egg hidden way in the background
but just before i get to that speaking
multiple languages isn't just a great
skill for breaking people out of foreign
prisons i'm sorry have my translation
skills been letting you down it's also
fantastic for understanding movies and
shows you love on an even deeper level
what does that mean and our video
sponsor babble makes learning a new
language a piece of cake as some of you
know from my videos on pixar's luca i
understood some of the movies italian
and now thanks to babble's award-winning
lessons with just 10 minutes a day i can
really improve my italian i volunteer
as you can see babble teaches you real
world practical conversations you'll be
able to use on your next trip or for
talking to friends or relatives and
babble has multiple ways for you to
learn according to what you like best
from podcasts to games and even live
classes there's a 20-day money-back
guarantee and as a very special offer
all our viewers can get a huge 65 off a
subscription by clicking on the link
below
now back at penhurst where nancy and
robin are about to meet victor creel
played by freddy krueger actor robert
englund there's a sign that prohibits
knives needles and razor blades a cheeky
hidden easter egg to kruger's iconic
bladed glove which was originally made
using steak knives and which in the
third film briefly features needles
while the scene with victor is all very
silent of the lambs robert englund also
gives another nod to his most famous
character when he scratches his nails
along the metal table in his cell
the gruesome design of wekner's enlarged
left hand and its distorted elongated
fingers and claws also tips its hat to
kruger's glove with its long
fingernail-like blades and during fred's
waking nightmare a vision of a little
girl accuses him with a finger that
grows into a horrifying pointed claw
like one of wekner's and the shot feels
like a twisted creepy version of et's
famous point especially given the many
other et easter eggs this season
and there's a sinister little detail
when one attacks using his left hand in
contrast to 11 who uses her right hand
to exercise her powers this is no
coincidence as in many cultures and
religions the left side has long been
associated with evil and bad luck which
is also why dr brenner's scars from the
demogorgon's attack in season one are on
the left side of his face
the way max will escape beckner's
clutches is foreshadowed during nancy
and robin's visit to penhurst we found
that music has a particularly calming
effect on the broken mind and on the
blackboard there's a list of records all
of which have titles related to dreams
and nighttime appropriately enough given
this season's villain i'll see you in my
dreams is about an ex-lover who the
singer still loves while red sails in
the sunset is sung by someone hoping
their loved one returns so both songs
fit nancy's situation with steve and
jonathan
and keeping with season four's dream
theme in suzy's room there's a poster
for the wizard of oz in which dorothy
wakes up to find oz was all a dream also
in her room are two posters for the
muppet movie a comedy road trip film
that reveals the muppet's origin story
and much like eleven's origin rainbows
are a big feature as is a song all about
dreams and dreamers
along with stephen king and john
carpenter steven spielberg has been very
much part of the show's dna since the
start and this season even the friendly
mailman who delivers post to joyce looks
like an absolute dead ringer for the
blockbuster director while i was pretty
shocked at first to see a spielberg
lookalike actor on screen if he was
going to pop up anywhere this was the
perfect storyline for it as the duffers
have said they deliberately channeled
his 1982 movie et for the whole
california setting
also check out the graffiti when dustin
rings steve about subbing into their dnd
game
[Music]
and the score gets very john
williams-esque especially after the cali
kids and mike up sticks and head to see
susie fun fact the duffer brothers music
of choice to listen to as they wrote the
first ever episode of stranger things
was john william's score for e.t
and the spielberg palooza continues with
super strong indiana jones and the
temple of doom vibes when joyce and
murray find themselves without a pilot
mid-flight as they saw over snowy
terrain below meanwhile back in hawkins
the show's hair and makeup department
channeled temple of doom's willy scott
for karen wheeler's new hairstyle plus
there's a raiders of the lost ark cut
out at the video store on top of that
there's a major homage to jaws when
steve returns from exploring the new
gate in lovers lake and scares the
others in the boat before he's pulled
down by a vine
and there's another nod to jaws via
beckner's first victim cheerleader
chrissy who shares her name with the
first victim in spielberg's shark
infested horror plus chrissy's surname
cunningham may well be a shout out to
arnie cunningham the main character in
john carpenter's horror film christine
based on stephen king's novel
and the way chrissy and the other
victims possessed by wekner float up
into the air has echoes of the evil dead
plus the way the vines wrap around the
victims also draws on sam raimi's film
as did hopper's experience with the
vines in season two
when dr owens tells al that she's needed
to win the war against the upside down i
believe you are our best hope our only
hope there's a definite ring of princess
leia's message to obi-wan kenobi in a
new hope help me obi-wan kenobi you're
my only hope and in another star wars
shout out dustin drops han solo's famous
ever tell me the odds during a game of
dungeons and dragons never
tell me
the odds and although l may mean more to
the workers at the nina project than the
queen of pop herself they're bigger than
madonna to them it's actually hawking
singer tammy thompson who gets to dress
up like the material girl
in some ways 11 and 1 are mirror images
of each other we're alike you and i and
after this season's revelations about
henry creel we can see how eleven's
experience of his evil actions sometimes
ended up reflected in some of her darker
moments later on so when she twists and
breaks the bully troy's arm in the first
season it's similar to how one twists
his victim's limbs before killing them
she also snaps a hawkins lab employee's
neck like one did to a guard in front of
her when she was younger and you can
discover even more easter eggs from
eleven and one's big showdown in my
ending explained video tap the link here
or in the video description below to
watch that so movie lovers what other
details and easter eggs did you notice
in the new season let me know in the
comments below tap here for my full
breakdown of the ending of part 1 and
what to expect in the big part 2 finale
and if you liked this video do leave a
thumbs up i really appreciate it bitchin
right yeah yeah bitchin thanks for
enjoying stranger things with me and
hope you have a marvellous movie loving
week yipikai movie lovers